i am janet cruz i am a primary school
teacher in the community of cruces
kakawatepek
is a rural village far from acapulco
about a year ago in march it was all
over the news that a pandemic was
affecting much of the world
authorities decided that we wouldn't
travel to rural communities
to protect ourselves the children and
the parents
a year has passed and we have not
returned to the classrooms
[Music]
learning at home is a program used
throughout the country for children to
take classes at home
according to the school grade but it
didn't work in this community
because they don't have tv sets they
don't have internet either
so we decided to travel to this village
every 15 days
to give children their homework on paper
or use textbooks
it's quite a long journey we cross
rivers the only roads are dead roads
we have seen how kids education has
declined
because we have not been in the
classrooms
help from parents has not been what we
hoped for
because most of them can't read or write
they work the fields all day
and the children stay home with no one
to help them with their homework
you open their books and they are empty
there's nothing on the notebooks
it worries me that parents take them
with them to work in the fields
and they might quit school
[Music]
it's going to be hard to get back on
track but with the help of parents
and teachers here at the school it's
possible
we want to motivate the children to help
them continue with their activities
to do the homework that would be a
return strategy